let's talk about the dallas cowboys
because they're front and center
tomorrow is the deadline for application
of the franchise tag the widespread
belief is that if the cowboys and dak
prescott don't get a long-term deal done
they will apply the tag for the second
straight year at the price
of
37.68 million dollars and chris i
explained this last week i can't
remember whether it was a sims day or
whether it was friday and you were in
your hammock yada yada
dax got a hell of a bird in the hand
37.68 million plus whatever happens next
year transition tag 45 million franchise
tag 54 million open market whatever
someone will pay that's here
so to get him to take this long-term
deal
they better make something that's as
good as that bird in hand and i don't
know they're going to be able to get it
done
all these years of them trying to get
him to do them a favor do you think all
of a sudden he's going to do them a
favor i don't i think he's getting
tagged
and i think that that this could be his
last year with the cowboys because they
have refused and they have failed
to to give him the offer that his
leverage dictates they want to pay him
based on other things he wants to get
paid based on his leverage and his
leverage is tremendous this year it
definitely is it's tremendous with the
crappy defense that they got
right i mean the running game is not the
force it was when he started as a rookie
and went 13-3 and did all those great
things that year right
that's not around anymore
i mean really the the crown jewel of the
football team is the passing game and
yet you know the quarterback
the quarterback and what we saw is very
important to that and dak prescott's
really damn good at it and he's got all
the physical abilities to take advantage
of all the things all those receivers
can do on that football team there's no
throw he can't make you know there's no
really systematic thing you can't do
with dak prescott in the pocket play
action on the run you know read options
all of those things like where what is
the deal here i don't know what the deal
is okay i really don't i don't get it
with dak prescott i mean
how much money is he asking on an
average year-to-year salary basis right
now i mean none of that's out now i
remember last year i know it was four
years versus five i know
here here's here
what i'm basically saying is just i
don't understand where dallas just why
can't you give him 37 million dollars a
year at this point or something like
that or just north
is that not good enough at this point
well here
chris ask yourself this yeah ask
yourself this right if you know you're
going to make 37.68 million this year
fully guaranteed right and next year
you're getting 45 or 54 or open market
is a multi-year contract with an average
of 37.68 million good enough to get you
to say
i'll do that
or nah i'll do this because i know i'm
getting 37.68 this year next year i may
get more i don't know now you're still
carrying some risk but then the question
becomes you do a five-year deal with an
average of 37.68 million or a four-year
deal how much of that's guaranteed see
that's part of where you got to get down
into the weeds of this definitely really
compare what the cowboys would offer
versus 37
known either 45 54 or open market next
year and i you don't get this far down
the kirk cousins path and stop
that's the other side of it look at what
he's done look at the risks he's taken
he's bet on himself he's carried the
injury risk and he suffered a serious
injury last year and he's still on the
brink of 37.68 million they still want
him there they just don't want to pay
him so they don't want to pay him what
his leverage would dictate they want him
to give up some of his leverage
as a favor
to
people who own businesses
for which they never do favor have they
do you think jerry jones is doing anyone
anything no
absolutely
leverage over someone do you think he
ever does someone a favor do you think
he pushes it to the limit that's how you
get and that's how you build an empire
and they're in the rare position of
being the ones whose
kahunas as you would say are being
squeezed
they want they want dak to stop
squeezing even though they would never
stop squeezing anyone ever well yes okay
so there's
there's a lot of things first off we
need to go back and look at like was
there do you remember any issues ever
with tony romo getting the new contract
or him being paid like a top quarterback
in football like i did but he took less
he
my theory on tony romo is is undrafted i
remember his first contract right what
in the hell is he doing it's the i'm
happy to be here i'm just happy to be
here but after the irony is he's now
making 18 million a year to talk about
football but but no he was never he
never pushed for top dollar never never
never pushed for top dollar but i think
that's how you're wired when you're an
undrafted guy when you're when you're
and that's kind of in the middle but the
highly drafted guys are wired to always
push for the top dollar the undrafted
guys i think it's easier to put the
cavorka on them to get them to just take
whatever they can get because they
shouldn't in their mind i shouldn't have
gotten it won the lottery just being
here right i mean that i just
i just can't believe we're still at this
point i guess is what i'm saying i
really can't you know the guy's a top
ten they've lowballed him for three
years they've loaded i know they've lost
they waited they procrastinated and
they've lowballed and no doubt now like
the the thing you come back to here like
you talked about there's still risk here
for dak prescott yeah i know we can make
the kirk cousins comparison and all that
but he did break his ankle this year and
when you hurt an ankle and have an
injury like that hey listen who knows
we've seen a lot of times in guys in the
in the history of football one injury
happens and now it starts to be other
injuries right you know all of a sudden
now it's always it's a knee this year oh
whatever it so that always would be a
scared of me that's what we're talking
about the risk factor at least for dak
prescott you know you could tear an acl
you can you know tear a labrum on your
throwing shoulder and it could be a
totally different game do you really
want to take that
that gamble to me that's still a big
gamble especially if like you said and
it goes really back to the guaranteed
money on the table so where okay yeah if
you played the franchise game and did
all of that maybe you could totally
maximize
but are we kidding me right now that the
dallas cab cowboys can't get a deal done
with guaranteed money that makes sense
for both sides and makes him feel good
and is the right average they can't i
just i don't care you know why because
they keep waiting and every time that it
gets delayed the price goes up and they
refuse to acknowledge that they still
think they can throw an arm around dak
prescott and talk him into seeing it
their way and they're gonna keep waiting
and they keep hoping he's gonna roll out
of bed one day and they got today and
tomorrow before the franchise tag gets
applied and he's gonna say okay i get it
i understand i'll do what you want i
mean if they have to apply that
franchise tag they're going into the new
league year where the salary cap is
going to be 180 283 million with 37.6
million of it
devoted to dak prescott they they can't
do that well the only way to avoid it is
to shrink the cap number by giving him a
contract that is strong enough to get
him to say i will release what i have in
my left hand 37.68 plus whatever happens
in 2022 and however it plays out it's
likely going to be good for me and even
if he has injury issues this year even
if he's not attractive on the open
market next year
he's got plenty of money in the bank
and he he hey i
i
rolled the dice i made the business
decision
i opted for this path and i'll live with
whatever the consequences are and he's
always been that way he'll live with the
consequences of taking that route okay
well listen i don't know what to say
what we don't know is really what's
being asked i we've never really known
you know we we don't know exactly it
one little thing came out last week yeah
i saw somebody suggest that
pat that dak prescott wants patrick
mahomes money and in a way you can argue
it is because well well new money
average for patrick mahomes is 45
million
value at signing yeah it's 39 million
right 39 million which isn't much more
than 37.68 so
but this is a way to try to do the pr
thing
with dak prescott because they want by
leaking it in that characterization they
want people to say who does dak prescott
think he is he's not patrick holmes the
giants did that to eli manning several
years ago when his franchise tag would
have made him the highest paid player in
football if he had played under his
franchise tag he's negotiating based
under his franchise tag the giants
leaked to medium members eli manning
wants to be the highest paid player in
football that freaked him out and got
him to take less than what his leverage
would have gotten him because that's how
he's wired it's not going to work on dak
prescott he's not going to blink in the
face of that bottom line is yeah 37.68
it's almost as much per year as pacman
homes is making i didn't make the rules
look this all traces back to the cowboys
are you using the franchise tag last
year to keep him off the open market
nobody knows what he's worth because the
cowboys have put an impediment in his
place to finding out and that impediment
this year is going to cost 37.68 million
there's an easy way to find out what
he's worth don't tag him don't tag him
and let's see what someone will pay him
that's their other alternative yeah and
no one has suggested they're even
thinking about doing that but maybe
that's what they should do well i i
don't know what they're i don't know
what they're thinking i really don't but
i would think that they could come to
some sort of an agreement or something
that would be able to get it done at you
know 37.5 million dollar average going
forward or something i understand so
what's a 37 plus you know 54
what are we gonna get to 91 million
there is that what we're talking about
they're not going to franchise tag him
next year no of course not do that so is
and guaranteed at signing money is that
what he's asking for because that's a
whole lot more than anybody else in
football so that's that's not realistic
so can't they find a common ground but
also give him you know you know the
guaranteed at signing and then the total
guarantee for injury and those type of
things too to where i don't that that's
where i'm just i don't know the the
specifics of the situation
back to my original point yeah
you got to convince him
to say
i will relinquish
what i currently have and what i
currently have is 3768 yeah transition
tag next year franchise tag or open
market you got to convince me to give
that up
and so he's got 37 that's all he's got
what are you gonna do that's all he's
got well you know what i'll stick i'll
i'll stick with this i'll stick with
this path how much you offer me fully
guaranteed uh i'll stick with this path
how much is injury guaranteed uh i'll
stick with this path you see if if i'm
todd france who represents dak prescott
my attitude is i'm perfectly fine with
this
and you got to change my mind well
what's it going to take oh you got to
change my mind keep trying we're not
bidding against ourselves too bad then
i'll take this path he's in a unique
position that i don't think any player
has ever been in where he's got
tremendous financial security and great
options for next year
and and i i'm just going to sit here and
wait for you to put something on the
table that i'll accept and if you don't
then you can pay me 37.68 million this
year and uh i'll hit the market next
year if you want to keep me you're going
to have to compete with whoever else is
going to try to sign me whether it's the
49ers the seahawks the bears whoever
whoever right
who plays the physical style of football
quarterback stays healthy coming off a
really bad 100 million insurance
policies
yeah i know but you know how that works
mike i mean nobody gets the insurance
policy you could be dead on a gurney and
they're like well he had three
heartbeats so we're not gonna give him
the money that's how it's it's a bull
crap thing and it barely ever happens
the insurance companies fight you to the
true career ending injury true career
ending yes okay but career limiting good
luck all i'm saying is i can't believe
we can't find guaranteed assigning
desean watson right now he got 73
million i can't believe we can't find a
common ground there to get to that type
of number and then somewhere at the
total guaranteed for injury which is
deshaun watson at 110 million which is
just north of you know people like uh
uh
carson wentz and uh russell wilson and
people like that i just can't believe we
can't get to that see that's where i
then i go into because the cowboys don't
want to they don't want to they wanted
to take a discount they wanted to help
the team they want to leave money behind
for other guys that's the that's the the
the jedi mind trick that they've been
playing on these guys for you i know
andrew the cowboys quarterback yeah it's
a great honor to be the cowboys
quarterback you get to make money with
all these sponsorship deals well i don't
know quincy carter wasn't making a lot
of money you got to be good to make the
money as the cowboys quarterback uh
but on top of that yeah that's what i'm
saying so
look all their devices and tricks that
work on all the other players have not
worked on dac and i feel like they keep
thinking eventually they will and the
longer they wait the more they're
realizing it's not working that's what's
fascinating about this chris this is the
guy this this is the guy
that would say to urban meyer i'm not
doing my pro day workout this is the guy
who is pushing the business approach for
his best interest for what's right for
him to the limit and it's gotten the
cowboys all twisted up that's what i
love about it we finally have someone
who is a top 10 quarterback not kirk
cousins who kind of stumbled into it
because washington was too dumb frankly
under bruce allen to give the guy a fair
offer and keep him around they didn't
realize that well just take 20 million
then 24 million that's what the tag was
those two years and walk away this is a
guy who is deliberately and
strategically standing in the face
of two extremely rich powerful and
persuasive owners jerry and steven jones
and saying
no
i'm not doing what you want me to do i
love that aspect of it well i i i do too
i respect it i do i think what we're
really basically getting down to here is
this it's plain and simple
i mean with the more i you just you get
to this because when you really look at
you know some of the numbers they might
have to meet or whatever i mean whether
it's
desean watson or close to it or just
north of carson wentz which of course
you know he deserves
more than carson wentz at this point
i i just the more i look at it the more
i go i just don't think dallas obviously
thinks dak prescott is all that that's
what it's starting to look like at least
from the outside looking in that they
don't think he's you know top five don't
tag it then don't tag him don't give him
37.68 million well i'll do it they're
not really to do that 37 they must be
good with that i don't know but
obviously there's something with the
guaranteed money at signing or total
guaranteed for injury that they're not
happy with i don't really understand it
i don't i mean i would think a jared
goff type deal would be very easily done
right i i don't know what the issue it's
57 million guaranteed of course he's not
going to take that he wants more than
that right it's 110 guaranteed at
signing all of that we can't get
somewhere around there and just north
and get the guarantee that's signing up
more
you know that that to me and going
forward those aren't big numbers to
where three two years down the road
we're not going to look at it and go oh
this is some crazy stupid contract so
well i guess what i'm getting to is that
dallas that just doesn't think he's that
great or is dak prescott asking for
you know patrick mahomes new average
money like you talked about which is
that's the 45.
yeah i don't think he wants 45. i i hope
not
but but what he wants and what and it's
not what he see that's the thing it's
not what he wants it's what are they
going to do to get him to give up what
he has
unlike these players who are typically
negotiating long-term contracts they're
under contract for multiple years
patrick mahomes had two years left jared
goff had two years left carson wentz had
two years left
so you're trading in two years where
you're not making all that much money
you're multiple years away from
beginning the process of putting the
screws to the team
so what they put on the table looks a
hell of a lot better because
you've got
more more needles you have to thread
before you get to the point where you
have the power dak prescott currently
has because he wasn't a first-round pick
because they've already tagged him once
he's five years into his career
he's sitting on a gold mine by way of a
franchise tag number the biggest
franchise tag number the nfl has ever
seen
that's
hey jerry
you who bought a 250 million dollar
yacht within the past couple of years
you have to convince me
to turn in my measly
37.68 and
and uh you know comparing it to this
contract none of that matters the
quarterback market doesn't matter what
matters is
what does it take to get dak prescott to
give up what he has 37
average no one in the nfl has ever had
before and no one in the nfl may ever
have it again because it's premised on a
team screwing things up enough to let it
get to this point with their current
situation and the way it's set up right
now
i i look at it and i think if if 37 and
a half is the average we're looking for
going forward i i would take that i know
that it is i don't know i don't know
what it is either i know i don't know
what it is so does he want to go north
of deshawn watson then
does it desean watson doesn't matter
what matters is i'm making 37.68 okay
here and i'm going to the market next
year oh i i choose that path okay unless
you convince me otherwise fine that
that's risky that's the metric i know i
i get that that's that's extremely risky
so i i don't know where they're at i
don't know how to answer that i don't
know where that that's at totally all
together i guess if he's asking for
crazy pass to sean watson money and all
of that yeah then i would think if i'm
dallas i might sit there and just we're
going to franchise him now hopefully we
can continue to talk about him get him a
deal that sits you know makes sense for
both of us as we go into here and before
that july date where you can no longer
negotiate long-term deals and you go
with it like that but i i i just i i
understand dallas too they're probably
looking at it going like dak you're
really good
but you're also not desean watson or
patrick mahomes yet that's that's not no
negative ghost rider we're not really
we're not going to go there yet either
so
none of that matters none of that
matters what matters is do they want to
keep him okay for more than this year
all right and what are you going to do
getting to stay for more than this year
well
you know from dak's perspective
this is a this is a product of the
system
that where he is right now is a product
of the system that was put in place in
1993 and tweaked in 98 2006 2011 and
last year this is the system with the
franchise tags and free agency and the
rookie wage scale he's drafted in 2016
and he's a fourth-round pick
and he gets peanuts yeah for four years
yeah and once he was eligible for a new
contract yes did they go to him and say
here is all the money that you should
have made the last three years plus a
lot more it's fair it's proper
no they didn't no they messed up and
they should have got them you're right
they waited and they kept waiting and
they kept waiting because they keep
hoping he's gonna wake up one day and
suddenly decide to do them a favor and
they use the franchise tag to keep them
off the market last year they used the
highest level of the franchise yeah
right that's why they're at 37.68 this
year they could have done 26 million
last year with the door open for someone
to sign him to a long-term deal that
they don't match and they get two first
round picks they went with the cadillac
level of the franchise tag last year i
remember last year somebody said oh
they're not going to tag him next year
why would you say that they used the
highest possible level of the tag this
year they want this guy but they don't
want to pay him see
what's the old saying you got to have
your cake and eat it too they want to
have their cake they want to eat it they
want to re eat it again they want to
keep their cake they want everything
they want everything and they refuse to
acknowledge the leverage that has been
created by their failure to pay the guy
fairly when the window opened to do so
yes i i you're right i can't argue any
of that i mean there's no doubt they
were stupid to the fact that they could
have got out in front of this
and certainly got them for the low or
lower than what they're having to deal
with right now and they're stuck they
are
but you know again i just it's risky all
i'm saying is it's risky for doc
prescott too
and also to think like not not as risky
he's got he made 31 million last year
he's going to make 37 million this year
he makes all that off the field
he's he's set
he's got his generation why does he need
the big money then just move on you're
telling them that they're signing for
30. oh hey chris wait but mike you can't
say you're setting you're not upset with
one year you're brainwashed i'm not
brainwashed but he's not you know how
much money is enough you know how much
money is enough yeah all of it no that's
how much is it i know that's how jerry
jones has lived his life okay so it's
okay for jerry jones but might be an old
argument
now you're saying he doesn't have enough
i don't know what you're doing i'm
saying he's got i'm saying he's got
enough that he doesn't have to worry
about the risk he's protected he's got
his safety net this isn't this isn't his
life is riding on whether or not he
takes this deal my point is when you
have an american oligarch in the form of
jerry jones who has consumed every
dollar he can and i've got no problem
with it i'm a capitalist but don't tell
dak prescott not to be a capitalist
either that's the problem i have with it
and that's kind of what you said how
much is enough all of it that's what's
enough well all of it well okay i i mean
if you're talking about like 91 million
dollars guaranteed and that everything
you can get everything you can scroll
well i don't know what that is that's
fine that's fine but there is a point
where it becomes like wait that's not
realistic that's not going to work so
yeah i understand dallas has messed this
up as well we don't know what dak
prescott's asking for all i'm saying and
you're right he has the franchise tag
okay fine all of it great all of it and
then you know yeah he can have all of it
but he also might be stuck with all of
that crappy defense he had last year too
to where you know him scoring
30-something points a game might not
matter
and that's not going to be all that
great either i know he has 37.5 there
he's still taking tremendous risk by
just doing that he is we saw this year
falls on his shoulder the wrong way bad
ankle gets hit in the knee now he's got
a bad knee and a bad ankle it's all gone
it's not going to be nearly as so this
is what he has right here then that's
all he's got if he wants to risk that
that's cool i got no problem with that
but i'm just trying to say there's a
balance and i don't have the answers to
what's being offered and not i don't
know i'm just i'm saying it's risky from
a guy who took one for the team and i
understand it like
i know i shouldn't have you're right i
get it but we just don't know the
particulars of this situation and it's
risky that's all i'm saying he's giving
me the side eye right here about taking
a less
if if you'd only known me back in 2005
how much more money you would now have
because i would have said don't do it
don't do it don't take one for the team
tell john gruden cram it um you
mentioned the defense yeah and of course
that's a big part of the the equation in
dallas is it enough to just bring in dan
quinn and and maybe run a defense that's
better suited to the personnel or or do
they need to find a way to upgrade or
both i i think it's dan quinn's gonna
help because they definitely have more
of a personnel that fits that defense
the seattle scheme and all that but i
think like mike you and i watched last
year
i don't care who you are or what they
got or what scheme they were in like
their defense was pitiful and they
definitely needed some difference makers
on the front four that's the one issue i
mean the one area i look at demarcus
lawrence is kind of underperformed yeah
you had the surprise randy gregory and
alden smith they were hey great was a
good stories but there's still nobody
dominant you know they got guys like
tyrone crawford who's been there for a
long time and done some good things and
had to deal with you know some injuries
but there's nobody there mike that's you
know you really look at other than
demarcus lawrence to where you go even
has the potential to be a game wrecker
so to me that's where it's got to start
for the dallas cowboys more than
anything is that defensive line and
getting some players there
yeah you know lawrence has been a
disappointment since he got his big
contract
while subject to the franchise tag a few
years back
they're hoping that randy gregory can
continue to develop alton smith do to
become a free agent no indication that
he's going to return they want they want
to figure out what's up with dak before
they know how much money they have left
to pay their other guys in a year where
the cap is going down and and of all the
teams that the cap going down has got to
affect in the negative one oh it does
because he said time and again
you would be surprised by the size of
the check that i would write to
guarantee that i would win another super
bowl he'd pay a lot for that he'd
probably pay yacht money for that super
bowl trophy that 250 million dollars on
that opulent yacht uh that uh uh may
need a new anchor you may have to sell
the anchor to pay that price all right
yeah yeah no no bait sales will be
needed no no bake sales will be needed
to help jerry jones finance the dak
prescott contract no no and when north
should it i get that but yeah yeah the
front four
you know their safeties are still an
issue right i mean we we heard that last
year
that that has to be changed it has to be
changed even more now when the seattle
defense safety it's a zone defense you
need special type of players back there
you know cornerback they still got some
some players there to where you go okay
they could make things work you know
they got every sign of cherdobia woozay
do they want to do that but they did
draft the trevon digs last year i mean
dallas has some work cut out in front of
them definitely i don't think it's a
huge overhaul though to where as bad as
it looked last year
i do think it's like hey they could get
back in the mix of things here real
quick you get a defen you know a few
little changes in the secondary some
defensive line the offense is still in
the spot if the dak prescott is there a
quarterback to where you go they'll be
able to move the ball on just about
anybody
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports